로봇은 지치지 않았습니다.
아니 더 정확히 말하면 지친 로봇은 충전하라고 했고
다른 로봇이 그 자리에 섰습니다.
2026년 5월 피규어 AI는 산호세 본사에서 이상한 생중계를 시작했습니다.
화면 속 휴머노이드는 택배 상자를 짚고
바코드 방향을 맞추고 컨베이어 위에 내려놓았습니다.
화려한 점포도 없었고 사람을 놀라게 하는 묘기도 없었습니다.
그런데 바로 그 지루함 때문에 사람들은 화면을 떠나지 못했습니다.
이 장면은 로봇이 사람처럼 생겼다는 이야기가 아닙니다.
로봇이 사람처럼 근무 시간을 채우기 시작했다는 이야기였습니다.
지금까지 휴머노이드 로봇 영상은 대부분 짧았습니다.
로봇이 걷고 뛰고 상자를 들고 계단을 오릅니다.
몇 초짜리 장면만 보면 미래가 이미 도착한 것처럼 보입니다.
하지만 기업이 진짜 궁금해하는 질문은 다릅니다.
그래서 이 로봇 하루 종일 쓸 수 있습니까?
이 질문이 이번 피규어 AI 라이브의 출발점이었습니다.
휴머노이드 업계에서 잘 알려진 스콧올터는 이런 취지의 말을 했습니다.
인간 도움 없이 8시간 풀타임으로 일하지 못한다면 휴머노이드는 상업적 가치가 없다는 겁니다.
피규어 AI CEO 브래데드 콕은 여기에 우리는 매일 그렇게 한다고 답했고
바로 그 다음 날 라이브를 켰습니다.
처음 목표는 단순했습니다.
8시간을 보여주는 것이었습니다.
그런데 방송은 거기서 끝나지 않았습니다.
하루를 넘기고 이틀을 넘기고 결국 100시간 때까지 이어졌습니다.
다만 여기서 중요한 오해를 하나 풀어야 합니다.
로봇 한 대가 100시간 동안 쉬지 않고 일한 것은 아닙니다.
배터리가 부족해진 로봇은 충전 위치로 이동하고 다른 로봇이 그 자리를 이어받았습니다.
그러니까 이번 실험의 핵심은 한 대가 얼마나 오래 버텼느냐가 아닙니다.
여러 대의 로봇이 사람 없이 충전하고 대기하고 교대하면서
하나의 작업 공정을 계속 돌릴 수 있느냐였습니다.
이 차이가 중요합니다.
휴머노이드의 상업화는 영웅적인 로봇 한 대가 모든 일을 해내는 방식으로 보장한 상태입니다.
실제 현장에서는 로봇도 쉬어야 하고 충전해야 하고 고장이 날 수도 있습니다.
중요한 것은 그때 공정이 멈추지 않게 만드는 운영 시스템입니다.
이제 휴머노이드의 질문은 바뀌고 있습니다.
예전에는 질문이 이랬습니다.
이 로봇은 사람처럼 걸을 수 있습니까?
지금은 질문이 이렇게 바뀌었습니다.
이 로봇은 사람 없이 한 교대를 버틸 수 있습니까?
그리고 앞으로의 질문은 더 차가워질 겁니다.
이 로봇은 하루에 몇 개를 처리하고 몇 번을 멈추고
사람보다 얼마나 싸게 일할 수 있습니까?
피겨 AI의 피겨 공사미안 작업은 겉으로 보면 단순합니다.
회사 측은 인간 작업자와 비슷한 약 3초당 1개의 처리 속도를 말하고 있습니다.
물류센터를 생각해보면 이 일은 별것 아닌 것처럼 보일 수 있죠.
하지만 실제로는 이런 일이 가장 중요합니다.
물류센터는 로봇에게 멋진 동작을 요구하지 않습니다.
지루한 일을 계속할 수 있는지를 봅니다.
같은 동작을 반복하고 실수를 줄이고 피곤해하지 않고
야간에도
돌아갈 수 있어야 합니다.
그래서 이번 데모가 의미가 있는 겁니다.
휴머노이드가 처음 노리는 시장은 사람을 닮은 로봇 시장이 아닙니다.
사람이 하기 싫어하고 기업이 자동화하고 싶어하고
기존 산업용 로봇이 애매하게 처리하지 못했던 반복 노동 시장입니다.
물론 이 장면을 곧바로 물류센터 인간 노동의 종말로 읽는 것은 성급하다고 볼 수 있습니다.
화면 속 작업은 실제 물류센터 전체가 아니라
비교적 통제된 한 공정이기도 하고 컨베이어 구조도 단순해 보입니다.
하지만 실제 현장에는 훨씬 많은 변수가 생깁니다.
찢어진 비닐 포장, 구겨진 바코드, 무게중심이 이상한 상품,
갑자기 옆을 지나가는 작업자, 멈춤 컨베이어, 주문 시스템과의 연동 문제까지
모두 해결해야 합니다.
실제로 전문가들은 이번 데모가 인상적이지만
아직 실제 물류센터 전체에 투입할 단계는 아니라고 평가했습니다.
장시간 작동 자체는 의미가 있지만
속도만으로 상업성을 판단할 수 없고
정확도와 예외 처리 능력도 함께 봐야 한다는 겁니다.
장시간 작동 자체는 의미가 있지만 속도만으로 상업성을 판단할 수 없고 정확도와 예외 처리 능력도 함께 봐야 한다는 겁니다.
하지만 바로 이 지점 때문에 이번 실험은 더 중요합니다.
이 영상은 완성된 미래를 보여준 것이 아닙니다.
앞으로 기업들이 휴머노이드를 어떤 기준으로 평가할지를 보여준 장면에 가깝습니다.
이제 로봇 회사들은
우리 로봇이 이렇게 자연스럽게 움직입니다라고 말하는 것만으로는 부족합니다.
실제 현장에서 몇 시간 일할 수 있는지, 몇 번 멈추는지,
사람의 개입 없이 다시 작업에 복귀할 수 있는지를 증명해야 합니다.
피겨 AI가 이 부분에서 자신감을 보이는 배경에는
BMW 사례가 있습니다.
피겨 AI는 이전 모델인 피겨 01을 BMW 공장에서 테스트를 했고
회사 발표 기준 12개월 동안 9만 개 이상의 부품으로 옮기는 작업을 수행했습니다.
물론 이 숫자만으로 상용화가 끝났다고 말할 수는 없습니다.
하지만 연구소 안에서 박스를 드는 것과
실제 공장에서 반복 작업을 수행하는 것은 전혀 다른 문제입니다.
공장은 로봇에게 멋진 동작을 요구하지 않습니다.
멈추지 않는 안정성을 요구합니다.
그리고 자동차 공장은 세계에서 가장 복귀한
복잡한 제조 현장 중 하나입니다.
부품이 많고 공정이 길고 품질 기준도 엄격합니다.
만약 휴머노이드가 이런 환경에서 일부 반복 작업을 맡을 수 있다면
그 다음 무대는 자연스럽게 물류 센터가 될 겁니다.
이 흐름을 보면 자동차 회사들이 왜 휴머노이드에 관심을 갖는지도 이해할 수 있습니다.
BMW는 피겨 AI와 협력했고 현대차 그룹은 보스턴 다이내믹스를 통해
휴머노이드 로봇을 직접 개발하고 있습니다.
자동차 회사들이 로봇을 보는 이유는
단순히 미래 이미지를 만들기 위해서가 아닙니다.
제조 현장의 인력 부족, 반복 노동, 안전 문제를
실제로 해결할 수 있는지를 보고 있는 겁니다.
여기서 한국 기업의 방향도 갈립니다.
현대차가 보스턴 다이내믹스를 통해
로봇 완제품에 가까운 전략을 가져간다면
LG는 조금 다른 길을 보고 있습니다.
LG 테크놀로지 벤처스는 피겨 AI에 투자를 했고
LG 이노텍은 휴머노이드에 들어가는
카메라 모듈 공급 가능성으로 주목을 받고 있습니다.
쉽게 말해서 현대차가 로봇 자체를
만들려는 쪽이라면 LG는 로봇의 눈과 부품
그리고 공급망에 들어가려는 쪽에 가깝습니다.
이건 스마트 시대와도 비슷합니다.
스마트폰 시장에서 애플만 돈을 번 것이 아니었습니다.
카메라 모듈, 디스플레이, 배터리, 반도체 회사들도
함께 성장했습니다.
휴머노이드 시대에도 비슷한 일이 벌어질 수 있습니다.
모든 기업이 로봇을 직접 만들 필요는 없습니다.
로봇이 많아질수록 그 안에 들어가는 부품과
센서 시장도 함께 커질 수밖에 없습니다.
그럼 이제 가장 현실적으로 와닿을 수 있는 질문을 한번 해보죠.
쿠팡 같은 물류센터도 조만간 휴머노이드 로봇으로 바뀌게 될까요?
답은 단순하지 않습니다.
당장 모든 사람이 사라지는 그림은 아닙니다.
실제 물류센터는 피규어 AI의 라이브보다 훨씬 복잡합니다.
하지만 일부 공정은 생각보다 빨리 바뀔 수 있습니다.
반복 분류 작업, 박스 이동, 무거운 물건을 반복해서 드는 작업처럼
사람이 오래 하기 힘든 영역부터 휴머노이드가 들어갈 가능성이 큽니다.
물류센터 전체가
한 번에 로봇으로 대체되는 것이 아니라
특정 구역이 먼저 로봇 작업살로 바뀌는 방식입니다.
그렇게 되면 사람의 역할도 달라질 수 있습니다.
직접 박스를 드는 사람에서 로봇이 멈췄을 때 문제를 해결하는 사람으로
예외 상황을 판단하는 사람으로
여러 대의 로봇이 일하는 작업 구역을 관리하는 사람으로 이동할 수 있습니다.
결국 피규어 AI의 라이브가 보여준 것은 완벽한 로봇 노동자가 아닙니다.
하지만 분명한 것은 전환점을 보여줬습니다.
휴머노이드의 미래는 영화처럼 거창하게 오지 않을 수 있습니다.
처음에는 아주 지루한 장면으로 올 가능성이 큽니다.
박스를 하나 짓고 방향을 맞추고 내려놓는 일, 그리고 그 일을 8시간,
24시간, 100시간 반복하는 일.
우리가 이번 피규어 AI 라이브에서 봐야 할 것은 로봇의 손이 아닙니다.
로봇의 근무표입니다.
휴머노이드는 사람을 닮아서 상업화되는 것이 아닙니다.
사람의 시간을 대신할 수 있을 때 비로소 산업이 됩니다.
그리고 그 첫 장면은 생각보다 조용했습니다.
컨베이어 앞에서 박스 하나를 들어올리는 로봇의 손끝에서 시작되고 있었습니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.